hey guys justin here with a gamespot  news update ubisoft has just confirmed  the watchdog season pass which includes  a sizable chunk of single-player content  including a new protagonist the watchdog  season pass will be sold for 1999 with  ubisoft claiming that'll be a  twenty-five percent discount on buying  the dlc individually season pass owners  will also get the dlc a week earlier  than the individual dlc purchasers the  new single-player content will have  players take on the role of t-bone  described as a brilliant but eccentric  hacker who lives by his own rules  there's also a new mode called digital  trip which has players hunting cyborgs  and an alternate game universe also  included are more single-player missions  weapons and outfits today nvidia also  announced that anyone who purchases an  eligible nvidia geforce gtx graphics  card will get a copy of the game for  free for a limited time we've always got  the latest watchdogs news right here on  gamespot com